[Musique]
c'est dans le magnifique jardin de la
villa du département que le président
souhaitait recevoir les agents partis
récemment à la retraite afin de les
remercier pour le travail accompli
durant ces nombreuses années au sein de
la collectivité
vous savez qu'une collectivité comme le
département qui emploie plus de 5000
agents
on a le devoir d'honorer celles et ceux
qui partent à la retraite parce que ce
sont des personnes qui ont travaillé
pendant trente quarante ans parfois de
leur vie au service des réunionnaises et
des réunionnais dans tous les domaines
de la santé de la petite enfance des
personnages et du sport de la culture
l'environnement dans les services divers
et variés et donc le devoir c'est de le
dire merci merci quand ils prennent leur
retraite et de la dia aussi que
maintenant c'est une nouvelle étape de
leur vie qui des morts alors profiter
pleinement de votre retraite
merci beaucoup bonne retraite à tout des
agents qui ont consacré leur carrière au
service des réunionnais la médaille
reçue ce jour représente pour chacun une
véritable reconnaissance un honneur
là c'est une reconnaissance envers nous
tout ce qu'on a fait tout ce qu'on a
donné tu arrivé au collège vauban le 2
novembre 1978 j'ai fait toute ma
carrière au collège bourbon et je suis à
la retraite depuis le février 2019
première j'étais militaire c'est dans la
marine pendant 15 ans ensuite j'ai passé
les concrétions entrer dans l'éducation
nationale entre ma jambe
j'ai fait trois ans les moins sincère
denis et les 16 dernières années j'ai
passé pour les all whites ont pour
avantage à polyvalent
quand j'ai quitté l'armée je partis y
avait rien
et la royale a reproduit une retraite
bien méritée dont ils vont pouvoir
désormais profiter pleinement
[Musique]